yeah things have since calmed down but
according to North Las Vegas PD three
men were stabbed just before 2 15 this
afternoon as you can see nothing so much
is going on behind me as of earlier but
now those men taken to UMC where they
are now being treated the severity of
each man's condition is unclear and we
are still awaiting information on what
led up to the stabbings and who was
involved we spoke to a man playing
basketball at the park who says he was
here when the incident occurred and saw
a large group of kids running in the
midst of it
just a big crowd and then the kid that
was covered in blood was like walked
right in front of me over here at the
court and like crossed that way he had
like this shocked face but his shirt was
all covered in blood it was a kid he had
to be a minor
as for suspect information and arrest in
North Las Vegas Police have not
confirmed anything now the main entrance
to this park continues to be blocked off
but as of now they're still trying to
avoid people from coming into this area
although there still are plenty of
people just around either playing
basketball or in the volleyball court
area all right reporting live Madison
Kimbrough 8 News Now